and most of the movies and TV featuring
AI that they don't describe it in quite
the way it's likely to actually take
place but I think you just have to
consider like even in the benign
scenario where
um if AI is much smarter than a person
um what what do we do
what what is that what job do we have
the biggest issue I see with so-called
AI experts is that they they think they
know more than they do
um
and I think they're smarter than they
actually are in general we are all much
smarter than we think we are but much
less smart dumber than we think we are
um by a lot so
this is this tends to play plague smart
people that they're defining themselves
by their intelligence and they they
don't like the idea that a machine could
be way smarter than them so they
discount the idea which is
fundamentally flawed it's The Wishful
Thinking situation
I try to convince people to slow down
slow down AI
to regulate AI this was futile I tried
for years mark my words
AI is far more dangerous than nukes
I I'm not normally an advocate of
Regulation and oversight I mean I think
once you generally you're on the side of
minimizing those things but this is a
case where you have a very serious
danger to the public
and therefore there needs to be a public
body that has insight and then oversight
on to confirm that everyone is
developing AI safely
this is extremely important
I think the danger of AI is much greater
than the the danger of nuclear warheads
by unlocked and nobody would suggest
that we allow anyone to just build
nuclear warheads if they want that would
be insane so why do we have no
regulatory oversight this is insane
better approach a better outcome is that
we achieve democratization of AI
technology meaning that no one company
or
a small set of individuals has control
over Advanced AI technology I think that
that's very dangerous
it could also gets stolen by somebody
bad you know like some evil dictator or
country could send their intelligence
agency to go steal it and gain control
it just becomes a very unstable
situation I think if you've got any
any incredibly powerful AI you just
don't know who's who's going to control
that so it's not as I think that the
risk is that the AI would develop a will
of its own right off the bat I think
it's more that's the concern is that
someone
um may use it in a way that is bad
um or or and even if they weren't going
to use it in a way that's bad that
somebody could take it from them and use
it in a way that's bad
that that I think is quite a big danger
I have to say that when you know when
something is the
a danger to the public then that there
needs to be some
I hate to say a government agency like
Regulators like I'm not the biggest fan
of regulators like he's a bit of a buzz
kill the fact is like we've got
Regulators in you know the aircraft
industry car industry deal with them all
the time uh with drugs food
um you know and anything that's sort of
a public risk and I think this has to
pull into the category of a public risk
and the intent with open AI is to
democratize AI power
um there's a quote that I love from uh
old Acton he was the guy that came up
with power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely which is that
freedom consists of the distribution of
power and despotism in its concentration
and so I think it's important if we have
this incredible power of AI that if not
be concentrated in the hands of a few
and potentially lead to a world that we
don't want usually it'll be something
some new technology which will cause
damage or death there will be an outcry
they will be an investigation years will
pass
there will be some sort of insight
committee they will be rule making then
there will be oversight eventually
regulations
this all takes many years
this is the normal course of things if
you look at say Automotive regulations
how long did it take for seat belts to
be implemented to be required the Auto
industry Fort seat belts I think for
more than a decade successfully for any
regulations on seat belts even though
the numbers were extremely obvious if
you had a seat belt on you would be far
less likely to die will be certainly
injured and the industry afford this
for years successfully
eventually after many many people died
Regulators insisted on seat belts
this is a this time frame is not
relevant to AI it can't take 10 years
from the point at which is dangerous
it's too late I'm really quite close to
I'm very close to The Cutting Edge in Ai
and it scares the hell out of me
is capable of vastly more than almost
anyone knows and the rate of improvement
is exponential it's going to come faster
than anyone who appreciates I think it's
with each passing year the
sophistication of of computer
intelligence is
growing dramatically I mean I really
think we're on an exponential
uh Improvement path of
um artificial intelligence and the
number of smart humans that are
developing AI is also increasing
dramatically I mean you feel like the
attendance at the AI conferences they're
they're doubling every year
um they're getting full
um
I have a a sort of a young cousin of
mine who's graduating from Berkeley
um in computer science and physics and
I asked him like well how
many of the smart students are studying
AI in computer science and the answer is
all of them what I'm trying to do is to
um
minimize the future existential threats
or to take whatever action I can to
ensure the future is good I think it's
the singularity is probably the right
word because we just don't know what's
going to happen once there's
intelligence substantially greater than
that of a human brain we are all of us
already our sidewalks so you have a
machine extension of yourself in the
form of your your phone and your
computer and all your applications you
are already superhuman
well by far you have more more powerful
capability than president United States
had you know 30 years ago
if you have an internet link uh you you
have an article of wisdom you can
communicate to millions of people who
can communicate to the rest of Earth
instantly I mean these are magical
powers uh
that didn't exist not that long ago so
everyone is already superhuman
and a sidewalk it feels like we are the
biological Bootloader for AI effectively
we are building it
and then we're building progressively
greater intelligence and the percentage
of intelligence that is not human is
increasing and eventually we will
represent a very small percentage of
intelligence
we're rapidly headed towards digital
super intelligence that water exceeds
any human I think it's very obvious I'm
not really all that worried about the
short-term stuff things that are like
narrow AI is not a species level risk it
it will result in dislocation in lost
jobs and you know that sort of better
weaponry and that kind of thing but it
is not a fundamental species level risk
whereas digital superintelligence is
so it's really all about laying the
groundwork to make sure that
if Humanity collectivity decides that
creating digital superintelligence is
the right move
then
we should do so very very carefully
very very carefully